et oui la grève d'aujourd'hui est aussi
une grande mise en garde aux deux
nouveau patron d'air france et d'air
inter qui ont été nommés officiellement
hier soir michel bernard dirigera air
inter et christian blanc air france ce
dernier est un spécialiste que l'on
qualifie spécialiste des négociations
difficiles il avait joué un rôle discret
souvenez-vous mais efficace dans la
réconciliation en nouvelle calédonie il
ya quelques années
portrait brossé par sophie jouve
christian blanc a de quoi être flatté
c'est lui l'ami personnel de michel
rocard que le gouvernement balladur est
allé chercher pour prendre des commandes
d'air france
il faut dire qu'à 51 ans ce bourreau de
travail peut se vanter de connaître tous
les méandres du secteur public
monsieur métro de 89 à 92
il a entrepris la modernisation de
l'entreprise la négociation il connaît
la fermeté aussi
et lorsqu'ils échouent imposer le
service minimum en cas de grève à la
ratp
il n'hésite pas à descendre du métro et
a donné sa démission sans état d'âme le
dialogue avec nos cheveux blancs est
quelque chose d'extrêmement difficile
c'est quelqu'un de dur dans la
négociation je dirai au personnel d'air
france de faire de prendre beaucoup de
précautions
en ce qui concerne leurs engagements
mais c'est aussi cette détermination ce
refus du compromis qui ont séduit et
guidé le choix du gouvernement christian
blanc est l'homme des affaires délicates
celui qui a su réconcilier en 88 la
nouvelle calédonie un beau succès
aujourd'hui christian blanc se donne un
peu de temps pour faire le tour de son
nouveau domaine
après quoi il veut avoir les coudées
franches et agir vite pour sortir air
france 2 sont des pieds une chose est
certaine il n'aura pas le droit à
l'erreur si mal